hey it's Hannah Elliot with Bloomberg
for suits and we're in Geneva a day
early to catch a sneak peek of the new
McLaren
it's the 675lt we've heard a lot about
it because of its incredible track
abilities 666 horsepower on a v8 engine
with a 0 to 62 mile per hour sprint time
of 2.9 seconds and a top speed of 205
miles per hour why so fast well the car
uses a special longtail air brake that
is 50 percent bigger than the one
McLaren used on its 650 s but that is
also much lighter thanks to the fact
that it's made from carbon fiber so the
whole car weighs just 2,700 pounds which
is more than 200 pounds less than its
predecessors this car sculpted with
complete speed in mind to a newly
designed front bumper and carbon fiber
front splitter arched wheel cavities and
a lean carbon-fiber side body that leans
into this subtle air intakes and
radiators even the two titanium exhaust
pipes integrate into the system
it all goes toward making this car
dominant on any track inside you'll have
race ready bucket seats and a clean
minimal interior that does nothing to
detract your attention from the grill
better yet the 675 LT is offered in a
few new bespoke colors and of course you
can still get it in the famous McLaren
orange but if I were you I'd try
something new such a great car as this
deserves a new look - this has been
Hannah Elliot with Bloomberg pursuits
and we just checked out the mclaren
675lt